oh
okay good morning representative
bartlett good morning mr chair good
morning commerce committee for the
record
i am representative christie dolette
bartlett i come from concord i'm
representing merrimack county district
19.
and i'm the prime sponsor of this bill
that was requested by the insurance
department
1559 is relative to laws administered by
the insurance department
good morning i am introducing at the
request of the insurance department this
omnibus type bill
which will make a number of minor
changes to several insurance statutes
it adds clarifying language in multiple
places
it specifies an agent's referral fee of
it adds rulemaking authority for paid
family medical leave insurance
allows reduced premiums during
extenuating circumstances e.g kovid
allows for notice provisions of a third
party when an insured cancels a
commercial policy
it adds language to explain the process
for liens on property in the continuing
care
retirement community statute
and marty mobley and heather silverstein
are here from the insurance department
to walk us through the bill and answer
any questions you may have
and thank you for your consideration of
good morning i'm marty mobley i'm the
legal coordinator with the insurance
department and with me today is heather
silverstein yeah so you unfortunately
have to have the mic really
good right there you go okay yeah sorry
okay nope i'll start again i'm marty
mobley i'm the legal coordinator with
the insurance department and with me
today is heather silverstein our general
counsel
and we like to walk you through the bill
i'll start with the first page in the
analysis i wanted to point out that ols
calls this a technical changes to the
laws administered by the insurance
department
we at the department have always
referred to this as an omnibus type bill
because there are though the changes are
minor and in our opinion fairly
innocuous they are not strictly
technical so that was something that ols
put on there that did not come from us
we do not consider this just to build
wild the changes that we're making
yeah i believe they do that so they
don't have to spell it all out
so starting with section one
regarding general premium tax report
this simplifies the the change we're
making here simplifies the language that
when an insurer submits their premium
tax report which is an annual thing it
just needs to be signed by a member of
the insurer's management team the
current language says verified by oath
or affirmation we're just saying let it
be signed and then adding the language
of the second sentence that clarifies if
any false information is submitted on
the report the person is subject to
prosecution per the falsification of
official matters statute so it's it
we're taking away the requirement that
it be an
affirmation but we're just letting them
know
don't lie
section two
our examinations in our examinations law
an insurer has 30 days to respond to any
issues contained in an
examination report
we're adding language here to make clear
that a request for more time to respond
may also be submitted during that 30-day
window and that is the practice we've
been doing but it is not clear in
statute that it is allowed to request
section 3
companies and agents insurance referrals
this changes for those instances when
someone is not licensed to write a
particular type of insurance so they
will refer the business to someone who
is properly licensed
typically there is a referral incentive
when this happens and with this change
we are stating that the referral fee
amount does not exceed 25
that's to clarify the vague reference
currently that says a nominal amount
that is that and we're saying that it
will not be more than 25
um that has been the practice but
now we're just putting it we're
codifying it in statute and just to make
it clear
uh section
four claim forms and applications
all forms and applications that are
approved in the state of new hampshire
require a statement that cites the
statute pertaining to insurance fraud
the current language suggests what the
substance of such a statement should be
we're just making the change to say no
just go ahead and put this whole
statement
this is the exact statement that way
it's not like well does this is this the
substance does this meet that
qualification to eliminate any confusion
on what we're actually looking for on
section 5 is regarding third party
administrator certificate here just adds
party administrator include on their
application when they're filling that
out the contact info for their preferred
service of process agent this is so the
department will know who to contact for
that service if and when it's needed
section six regarding property and
casualty rate filings
i'm currently in statute the commercial
inland marine insurance carriers are
exempt from filing their rates with the
department if the policy is not written
according to any manual rates or rating
plans
the department believes this is a
disincentive to carriers who use rates
that are supplied by rating bureaus as
those rates are contained in manuals
these rating bureaus adhere to the
rating standards set out in rsa41215
and they produce actuarially sound rates
that support the market and which can we
be relied upon with confidence so we're
just letting them know that it's okay to
section seven the patient's bill of
rights
currently an insurer is required to
provide a copy of the patient's bill of
rights to a policyholder
we are proposing a change that clarifies
this requirement only applies to major
medical policies as that is the intent
behind rsa 151 21 which is the patient's
bill of rights so as to eliminate any
possible confusion about when an insurer
is required to provide this document to
their policyholders it's just a
clarification does that mean not if
you're using your med pay on your auto
insurance
is that
an example of what you don't have to do
right
exactly it's only for major medical
policies so if you're getting a short
term limited duration or an ancillary
health product or anything like that you
do not need to provide that disclosure
that help
section 8
line 13 general group or blanket policy
provisions and this is just adding the
same language to the group policy
statute so
they don't if it's
the first the first to the change in
seven is for individual policies the
change in aid is for group policies the
same thing now it's only if it's major
medical does the patient's bill of
rights need to be given to the policy
holders
and then sections 9 through 11
are the changes that will grant
authority to the insurance department to
define regulate and promulgate rules for
paid family medical leave insurance
we currently we don't have specific
authority to regulate those products we
do have general rulemaking and
regulating authority under our general
um
rsa400a
but this will give us specific authority
to do that so that we can do our jobs
let's see
and go on over to the next page section
12.
starts on page
3 line 16
unfair insurance trade practices rebates
rsa 417-4
lays out what constitutes unfair trade
practices for the insurance industry
paragraph 9 of this statute states that
offering rebates as an inducement to
purchase insurance is prohibited
however subparagraph b under paragraph 9
describes those actions that shall not
be considered rebates and we are
proposing to include language here that
will not considered as rebates those
activities that promote the public
interest such as offering temporary
premium reductions during extenuating
circumstances that in fact that affect
the entire insurance marketplace like
during covid when carriers wanted to
reduce temporarily their premiums
because they weren't receiving claims
nobody was driving
section 13 refusal to issue cancellation
and refusal of automobile insurance
here we are adding language to clarify
that a company may not issue
excuse me may not issue a notice of
cancellation for non-payment until a
customer does in fact not pay their
premium on time
this change will make the department's
position clear if there ever is an issue
regarding the date of a cancellation
section 14
commercial cancellation grounds grounds
for cancellation
last year if you'll remember we modified
the language in this statute to allow
for the cancellation of a commercial
policy at the specific request of the
policy holder the insured because that
was not before an allowed cancellation
and we are proposing language here to
make clear that the the insured must
still meet the noticing provisions
contained in their policy
when they request that cancellation but
that the company may not have more than
10 days to act upon the cancellation
requests
and this change will eliminate any
confusion currently it looked like
before it was like it could happen
immediately we had some concerns from
insurance companies that they their
policy required more notice than
immediate so we are making that change
and section 15 continuing care
communities
rsa 420 d9 allows the insurance
commissioner to file a lien against the
real and or personal property of the
provider of a community care community
in order to protect the interests of the
residents of that community if necessary
we are adding language here to make
clear that any such liens will be filed
and registered in accordance with rsa
478 which is the register of deeds
statute as the current language and our
statute does not sufficiently indicate
how such liens are to be recorded and
processed
so
as i say they're they're not strictly
technical changes but there's they're
pretty mild
and we'll answer any questions
well i feel like i wrote clarify
the statue a lot here so it feels like a
lot of it's just
making sure that people really
understand exactly what you mean exactly
exactly um how much of this comes from
the department or is any of this from
the audit
you know when you guys have audits
how much is so
um good good morning i'm heather
silverstein general counsel at the
insurance department so
most of these changes come from us
we we are working through things and we
realize this is not working we need to
change this it's not working for us it's
not working for industry it's not
working for consumers uh whatever the
case may be so this is our way of going
through and trying to fix the things
that are not fitting neatly like they
should i mean a good example of that the
first one was related to premium tax
there's always been an issue about
getting a notary that became even more
difficult during the covet emergency
with regard to companies having to sign
through a notary so this is an easy
switch out you sign but then you're
you're also saying you can't falsify the
report because you can get in trouble
for that and that that takes away that
but you know
these things have always been like a
little bit clunky it made it even worse
during covid
and so we're trying to focus in and
um fix those things the same thing with
examination reports you know it
shouldn't be an issue that someone can
that a company can ask for a 30-day
extension to work out the details of a
report and to try to work with the
department you would want that
flexibility that's what we want so we
great
any questions from the committee members
i think you might a lot of stuff here so
unlike the senate we don't execute bills
the same day because you never know
something people might read this and say
geez i need more clarification on what
that means so
it's worse
but at this point i think we're all set
thank you
and having no cards but i can see the
blue sheet uh
has that george russos who decides to
take up five lines here
and uh says that he is in uh big time
support because he did the x multiple
times
jim hayden from state farm insurance
also in support and john
pagano
okay
great
and they're all in support and
in on
line last night we did have one person
is in support uh
daniel richardson
so with that i will close the public
hearing
15.59
okay great
perfect
it's uh 10 10 45 a.m
uh we're here to
introduce house bill 1558 and to
introduce that is representative hunt
good morning
members of the commerce committee i'm
representative john hunt representing
ringen fitzwilliam
and today i'm introducing a another
departmental bill insurance department
bill
uh it this is uh this is nic
model law
and it's related to receiverships group
capital calculations liquidity stress
testing for internationally active
insurers and these changes are an
accreditation standard
and doug bartlett will help you out so i
just want to spend one moment for make
sure everybody understands what we're
doing what this is
so remember how we were talking about
the ucc
as being this model legislation that
comes down
and that model legislation is created by
you know smart lawyers and connected
with all across the country but it comes
out of chicago
they have created this entity in chicago
that creates that model legislation
insurance as some of you might be
familiar is a territory that is treated
sort of like the ucc in the sense that
um insurance regulator is uh in that
state so if you are
starting an insurance company the first
thing you think about is what state i
want to do this in because that state is
going to be your regulator
okay and it's very important that that
even though you might be selling
insurance products all across the
country or internationally wherever
your regulator is not the federal
government
it's actually the insurance department
in the state in which you don't missile
so
same issue came up with well we want to
make sure that every state is doing the
same deal that there aren't too many you
know doing anything too crazy from one
state to another
and that's where we get the uh national
association of insurance commissioners
and i see and i see so nic
that is is designed to create model
legislation that is then distributed to
the states
and hopefully they all enact it um and
you and you actually get rated on how
well you're doing in terms of uh
upholding the nic standards
and again that is the attempt to unif
have a uniform
statutes across the country
but that at the end of the day
it is the individual state that is the
regulator and with that i will then
allow
any questions if anybody has any anybody
okay saying no questions
uh i have a card from
doug bartlett for new hampshire
insurance
chairman members of the commerce
committee
i'm doug bartlett
i am the director of financial
regulations
for the state of new hampshire insurance
department
this bill incorporates updates
to an insurance model act
regarding the group capital calculation
and
the liquidity stress testing for
internationally active insurance groups
new hampshire is the u.s group-wide
supervisor of the u.s insurers in the
rsui group which is part of a larger
allegheny group because
there are insurers within the allegheny
group which are mainly in the
transatlantic holding group that write
in foreign you mind speaking a little
bit louder so
we can do get recorded right
back up a little bit okay new hampshire
is the group-wise supervisor of the u.s
insurers in the rsui group which is part
of a larger allegheny group because
there are insurers within the allegheny
group which are mainly in the
transatlantic holding group that right
in foreign countries we need this law
the revisions to the naic insurance
holding company system regulatory act
model 440 which is our equivalent or the
new hampshire rsa401b
were unanimously adopted by the neic to
enable the requirement for the group
capital calculation
and the liquidity stress test
this is an accreditation standard
for any state that is the lead state and
has insurers in a group that right in
foreign countries
and just uh
to to add what
the chairman hunt said
an accreditation standard in in usually
you see if you see an accreditation law
you i'm going to be the one you're
talking to
it's it's usually to do with
you know financial regulation and things
like the holding company and just
supervising uh supervising insurers
because you know i i you can't have
different states
having different rules
for
uh
insurance regulators have adopted a
group capital calculation
for use in the solvency monitoring
activities the calculation is intended
to provide additional analytical
information to the lead state for use in
assessing group risks and capital
adequacy to complement the current
uh holding company analysis for the u.s
the liquidity stress test considers the
financial institutions ability in the
absence of the market of funding
liquidity
to meet obligations during periods of
stress by accurately measuring the
liquidity profile of the balance sheet
in an enterprise wide level
these tools are in addition to other
tools such as enterprise risk management
reporting form f
supervisory colleges and these things
were added to our rsa 401b back in 19
and the own risk solvency report which
was made in separately rsa401c
which was enacted in 2015. so it's it's
just a as as new tools come along we add
them to the holding company law and i
would be happy to answer any questions
great any questions from anybody and
quite a long document somebody
i think yes
we know better than to ask doug any
questions
all right
so representative pull that microphone
real close to you okay so if i
understand correctly uh
new hampshire is a designated is a lead
state is that what you said it's a lead
state for the group
the lead state is determined
when you have
let's say you have five companies
the company that rights to the state
because it could be more than one
company in the state in this case three
of the companies are in new hampshire
okay and we have the volume
of premium in the united states
therefore we're designated as the lead
state okay so okay so in other words
if i understand correctly these changes
uh
enough liquidity or whatever the word is
collateral so that these
corporations can stay in the state and
yeah
yes and so they can operate in the world
right yes
some of the numbers are really big so
well this is this is like i say is it is
this
you know we are also the lead for delta
dental
well you know they're not going to be
writing in foreign countries
uh saying the hanover they're not going
to be lead for the hanover they're not
going to be ready in four countries but
this
this company happens to have
uh members um
or insurers within the group
that right in foreign countries okay so
i just wanted to make sure
what we were accomplishing here and it
sounds to me that
we want our status to remain that's what
we need to do
yes
thank you
think of it like a bond rating
and we want to we want to be triple a
so we do we do this we keep up to date
and and as long as you dot the eyes and
cross the t's then you
you have that credibility
and so
and this is really for insurance
commissioners of other states or
countries to say evaluate
a company who's coming in to sell their
product if they want to decide whether
they really want them to be in their
state or in their country is to say okay
so let's look at their regulator and is
their regulator got the aaa
ranking
would you believe
yes
uh
let's see i have nobody online
and joan again is uh
from the big eye is in support of the
bill
and with that i will close the public
hearing
okay
we open up the public area in house bill
1019 the prime sponsor is unable to make
it so uh
representative patouzik is going to read
his testimony
speak loud and clear so we get it thank
you mr chairman is this loud enough
yes you do thank you uh house bill 1019
oh for the record representative john
patosik representing rockingham six
which is derry new hampshire
hb 1019 establishing a committee to
study the replacement of certain
professional licenses with a mandatory
minimum liability insurance requirement
the analysis states this bill
establishes a committee to study the
replacement of certain professional
licenses with mandatory minimum
liability insurance requirements
representative mike harrington is the
sponsor and i'm going to read what he
asked me to read
chairman hunt and commerce committee
commerce and consumer affairs committee
members i am the prime sponsor of hp
1019 but due to a change in my schedule
i am not able to attend today's hearing
so i am
submitting this written testimony
instead
this bill would establish a committee to
study the replacement of certain
professional licenses with mandatory
liability insurance requirements
over the years there have been a
proliferation of laws requiring a state
license to perform various professions
the thought being that if the government
does not regulate and licenses those
performing these occupations the public
safety would be in jeopardy
this bill would study the possibility of
requiring liability insurance instead of
obtaining a government license
this effectively would have the
underwriting insurance company regulate
the profession
this is not new con this is not a new
concept
insurance companies impose many
requirements on their policy holders and
perform inspections to be sure that they
are met
this idea is being looked at by other
states and the study committee would
investigate as to whether this approach
could or would work for new hampshire
i would like to leave you with a with an
example of a potentially very dangerous
profession where there is no government
regulations
oversight or professional licensing
requirements
that profession is scuba diver
instructor
scuba
is excuse me scuba diver instructors are
certified by private organizations such
as the professional association of
diving instructor instructors padi
there are no laws that dictate how they
do this
they develop their own standards and
have certified thousands of instructors
who have certified millions of students
so what are the results
while scuba diving puts one in a hostile
environment where lack of proper
training and
equipment could lead to death it has
been shown to be a very safe activity
who could have imagined
properly chained people performing what
could be a dangerous activity in a very
safe manner without any government
involvement
the rules of organizations such as padi
go beyond just training however
try to get on a dive boat or rent dive
equipment without a diver certification
card and you will be quickly told no way
again there is no law that prevents this
just the fear of liability should
someone rent diving equipment to someone
who is not certified
i would ask you to give this bill
careful considerations and i will be
available to answer questions after 2 13
february
p.s if i'm mike i checked the new
hampshire laws and there are only two
that deal with scuba diving both deal
with navigation and state requirements
for putting up a flag while diving and
the penalties for boats that go into the
boating exclusion area around the flag
that ladies and gentlemen is my
testimony from mike harrington there's
supposed to be someone here
who can answer any technical questions
about this
thank you
okay
okay well thank you very much for your
testimony
so i have two cards one for one guest so
we'll
um unfortunately the one against is is a
representative so we always invite
representatives up first
even though they're in opposition
but
when when you have another chairman in
the in the committee room you always
treat them with a great care because you
when you're in front of their committee
you want to get the same
special treatment so will infant time uh
in
opposition to the bill thank you mr
chairman
i'm speaking today on behalf of the
electricians board i am the vice
chairman of the new hampshire
electricians board and have been for a
number of years
there are approximately 52 different
organizations under the oplc
that are
where we have licensed
individuals
liability insurance
covers bodily injury and property damage
it doesn't have nothing to do with
enforcement
and as electricians there are things
that if done wrong
so
it's not only getting licenses which is
dealing with making sure you have
certain education
requirements and certain
amount of hours
then has to do with enforcement and when
enforcement finds that people violated
the rules they can been brought forth
in some kind of disciplinary action
my wife also used to serve on the
cosmetology board
similar things there
where
places where
utilizing or violating
their licenses by utilizing
chemicals and other things
that were either banned in the state of
new hampshire
or they were doing things that were
harming individuals
i'm sure you know that very well
representative
um
so
this does not work in every mechanism it
may for some of the smaller ones scuba
self-contained underwater breathing
apparatus i loved learning that when i
was a kid
so
that may be so in that case and i know
we're trying to reduce the amount of
occupations that are licensed
some may be frivolous and not needed but
by and large some of the major
licenses held
and managed by the oplc
offer
the education
training enforcement
and then um
disciplinary action
for not following those rules and it is
important and it can't be done
just through a liability policy as you
know also no
i'm the national member of the new
hampshire insurance agents association
on a national level
as i said it's bodily injury and
property damage is covered by a
liability policy much more narrow but i
will let our executive director speak
from an insurance standpoint
so i know there's a study committee and
i know we're really happy to have study
committees these days but um this is uh
probably not
uh applicable for some of the major
licenses
that are held here in the state thank
thank you so i i was going to ask john
the question but i'll ask you first and
then junk and answer it
so i when i first read this i was a
little
uh confused i wasn't sure exactly where
it's going obviously we heard the
testimony but
because i always think about
we have requirements for bonding
requirements
but the idea that we have
liability insurance requirements in
terms of the other i mean i don't know
you sell these products how often are
you complying with somebody's insurance
you know a legislative mandate that they
have liability insurance versus just the
i know as a legislature we try to stay
out of putting
insurance limits in
law we do have so in the condo law i
know but we try to keep it up because
you know what what limit you put in now
10 years from now is going to be
obsolete so we try to stay away from
that
bonding the two types of bonding you're
talking about mr chairman uh one is a
financial guarantee uh to
complete a compet to complete a
construction type project it covers um
uh
performance bond
guarantees the performance of the
project the payment bond guarantees that
it will be paid the other type of bond
fidelity bond
guarantees you will follow the rules or
you will pay a penalty
um but
right fidelity bond yeah but
but i know like real estate agents so we
we require a bond 25 000 bond a lot of
times that has to do with because
they're taking deposits you're taking a
i don't really know there's ever going
to be a fine that that's going to be
paid for i think it's a financial
portion of that
okay but again liability is bodily
injury and property damage has nothing
to do with some of the other things
other reasons a um a license in place
and quite frankly
uh all the rules and we have in place
for the electrician's board i don't
believe there's any insurance criteria
to totally do that's what i'm saying
most bond they don't have insurance
requirements they might have some
bonding requirements but they don't have
insurance requirements that's what i'm
thinking that's correct
okay
great all right thank you very much for
your testimony
all right so i i'm sorry ross i saw john
i missed jones card so let me have her
come up first and then you can get the
chance to wrap it up
okay joan
so maybe you want to tell people what
the big eye means
good morning thank you mr chairman and
committee members
my name is joan pejo i'm the president
of the new hampshire association of
insurance agents also known as the new
hampshire big eye and i serve as their
lobbyist
our members are the independent
insurance agents located in all the
communities across the united across new
hampshire
there are over 200
agencies our members have over 200
office locations throughout the state
and we are opposed to this bill
understanding that the bill is to
establish a committee i think it's
important to look at the goal
which is to replace certain licenses
with an insurance policy professionals
especially in
and speaking for the insurance
industry work hard to become licensed we
study we pass an exam
and then through continuing education we
learn we continue to learn the nuances
of
one's chosen career
consumers rely
on professionals to give good advice
provide quality services and products
and the best way to make sure that
getting this good advice is to verify
the professional is licensed
we believe
substituting a hard-earned license
required regulated by the state for an
insurance policy that could be canceled
the day after it's taken
is putting consumers at great risk
thank you and i'm happy to try to answer
great so if i get your testimony
correctly he said
if we put this in the statute somebody's
got to look over to make sure that that
license that liability insurance is
always in place
and that's usually what a a licensure
board
would be doing or a licensed board is
going to make sure that the professional
is
maintaining and is in good standing with
their license
you know a good professional is going to
make sure that they're properly covered
with the insurance industry they
purchase professional liability
so if they make a mistake an insurance
company is going to step in to represent
them
in the event that they're sued
what i see with this bill is that
they are putting
the onus onto the insurance company to
make sure that that professional is
rising to the standard that the the
consumer needs and i think that
is a mistake again because an insurance
policy can be purchased today
great
any questions
see none thank you very much thank you
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee for holding this hearing today
just for the record my name is ross
connolly i'm the deputy state director
for americans for prosperity
uh we are neutral on the bill but we
support its intent
uh
for for a host of reasons uh
occupational licensure is is the most
burdensome form of government regulation
requires thousands of hours in some
cases of training
lots of monetary investment as well and
according to the institute for justice
their study license to work showed 16 of
new hampshire's workforces licensed and
due to onerous uh regulations associated
with those licenses an estimated eight
thousand thirty two jobs are lost
and and before the pandemic
the department of employment security
cited barriers to entry as a driving
force behind uh granite staters not
being able uh to acquire a a job and
that has only been exacerbated for from
what we've seen
uh post-pandemic or or during the
pandemic uh that
this barrier is is difficult for people
to cross to especially low-income folks
to to enter into licensed fields
so we support uh looking at alternatives
to licensure that removes some of those
barriers that are preventing people from
entering the license field but also
protects consumer safety i i can't speak
specifically to this i only found out
but uh so i can't speak specifically to
the limited liability insurance but we
do uh use uh
hold up this chart of just uh some
alternatives to licensure that
legislators can look at this was
something we supported a couple years
ago
it was called the board reform act and
and it would have created a committee
similar to this bill but having all
these options that the committee could
analyze
alternatives to licensure uh that that
does still protect uh consumer safety so
things like fraud depending on the
industry uh
there's a correlative
option that that we can list that that
reduces that burden but uh protects the
public safety
um
as as has been pointing out that this
bill all it does from my reading is it
establishes a committee to study this i
i would advise maybe having some other
options for
uh for licensure not just the limited
liability insurance as
as has been pointed out that may not
cover
be a good option for every single
industry that's licensed so having some
other other options uh would probably be
advisable
um
again we support the intent uh we
applaud the sponsor for for looking for
these options since this is it's one of
the highest
of of licensed fields it's one of the
highest amount of people employed in the
state uh so it's a huge amount of the
workforce and and we should be looking
at alternatives to make that easier so
so with that i'd be happy to try and
answer any questions that could
committee may have
represented burroughs has a question
yes i don't know if you can answer it if
representative petusa can i'm wondering
if there are any specific industries
that were of concern when the bill was
written
he's not the sponsor
no i know he's not but i asked if he
might no
thank you for the question
representative i i i can't speak to to
what uh industries the sponsor may have
had in mind uh i but there there are
many fields and there's
a whole host of bills if you go talk to
uh representative mcguire over an edna
i'm sure she'll she'll tell you about
the list of bills that that they get uh
looking at making changes there was one
on athlete's agents there last year
there was one to remove the license for
lightning rod inspectors
things like that we have a lot of
licenses where there could be
improvements uh made to statute to
reduce that burden whether it's just the
the regulations on the amount of hours
required or or the fees included
there's a lot of areas we could look at
uh i but unfortunately i can speak to
what the sponsor had in mind thank you
representative below
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
i'm a licensed cosmetology i have been
for
nearly 50 years
and um close to the mic um for several
years i've been a cosmetologist and i
did go through
the course
the you know and um the licensing um you
know the
the test that you have to take
and
we learned an awful lot i mean there's a
lot involved in cosmetology
so would you feel comfortable going to a
salon
where
the hairdresser or the barber
was not um
didn't go in it didn't go through any
type of you know
licensing uh procedure or
uh the 1600 hours
uh thank you for the question
representative i i would say it depends
uh so it depends of what it would be
replaced with if we just remove the
license and replace it with nothing
that's probably not a very good idea i i
think having something to to back up and
protect consumer safety
uh and whether you know cosmetology and
that's that's a very wide-ranging field
uh
years ago we we got rid of the license
for hair braiders since hair braiders
were required to have uh the full
cosmetology license even though they
only covered one specific area so i i
think looking at uh each industry of
where
you know
some of those those regulations may not
be necessary is probably a good place to
start i you know starting with let's
just get rid of all the licenses uh
would not be a good move for consumer
safety so i think having a commission
that could look at what areas could be
changed without putting the public at
risk and uh you know
opening up that field to more people
would be a good good route to take so
studying it instead of jumping ahead
would probably be the better route to
take and just a follow up for the
question main choir yes
if there is a study committee formed and
there is not a hairdresser or
how would you make decisions
relating to that industry
uh thank you for the question
representative i i think uh as this bill
is i believe it's all members of the
legislature uh so similar to someone
like jail car looking at uh this and
just
but opposed the jail car they wouldn't
have any actual power it would be
advising uh the committees like this one
on what uh changes they could make uh
since the licensing fields again there's
many of them
uh it can be very complicated going
through each each license
uh so i
i i think that's sort of the the
direction to go in uh is having the
legislature and a member like yourself
could be part of that that commission
that does have experience in that field
thank you
representative
next
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking our questions uh would you agree
uh that there's a there's a goldilocks
zone when it comes to regulating
industries it's you know not too hot not
too cold just right
and it's a balance between consumer
protection
and protectionism within the industry
would you would you agree and uh could
you speak to that
uh thank you for the question
representative yes i i would agree that
um
there is a certain amount of
protectionism within licensed fields uh
you know obviously if somebody goes
through the training goes through
a very onerous and burdemsome
system to get to get their license they
may not want others to uh to have an
easier time uh but i i think
uh largely it's it's more of driven
by uh
by this idea that it does protect
consumer safety we have there's multiple
studies that show depending on the
license field that it actually
doesn't do anything to protect consumer
safety and again there's
many many many lists and i i can submit
that to the committee in written
testimony of
fields that are currently licensed in
the state of new hampshire that may not
necessarily need to be
and that an alternative would be a much
better
representative bartlett
thank you mr chair
um i'd like to leave aside the idea that
in this bill and we're just going to
talk about this bill
we're asking for a study committee that
would go through the house
go through session go over to the senate
um go through the senate committee
process
if it were passed then it has to go to
the governor
before this could happen and this is the
second year of a biennium put that all
aside to see if this could all get done
before july
july because we don't meet after july
and then we've got campaigns
so that
probably makes the fall pretty tough
um how do you think that
just in just looking at this bill
the enforcement would be addressed would
that be government enforcing or would
that be insurance companies enforcing to
make sure that there was a liability
policy in place
uh thank you for the question
representative
as i pointed out in my testimony i can't
speak directly to the the insurance
liability portion of this bill i i don't
know how
uh that that will actually
impact things we were just speaking
generally to looking at alternatives to
licensure uh
it's
how how it would play out what we would
prefer would be similar to the board
reform act which over the course we we
predict this would take years to
actually go through every licensed field
look at every little regulation
uh so we we would probably prefer to
have a prolonged uh commission that that
can oversee this since it would take a
lot of time and effort to go through
this and as as you pointed out that
that's probably not going to be the case
in in this this year
uh so i i would probably advise to
stretch out that time period of that
they would have to study uh the licenses
representative mclaren
um yes you you mentioned that you had a
list of uh
occupations that you didn't think uh
licensing was
was necessary do you have that list i
would like to see that list and i would
like to see
i'm assuming that you have the reason
why
you don't think that
a license might be needed thank you
thank you for the question
representative we have a just an initial
look at you can look at the institute
for justices licensed to work that's
that's a great place to start where they
look at the the low income
you know the the most burdensome we look
we consider those low income entry level
positions that that that's where we're
not talking about doctors lawyers
uh some of the really highly technical
fields some of the those lower entry
level
fields uh we believe that uh changes can
be made to reduce that that burden of
entering the field a lot of people that
are low income
can't for instance pay tens of thousands
of dollars for training and take years
to to go through
uh all of the
the hour requirements uh so
whether it's looking at
eliminating a license like lightning
rods or
last year this legislature removed uh
the law that made it illegal to cut
somebody else's hair without pay uh that
was kind of made national news
those little things are are an area that
we can look at of removing some of those
uh those areas that it's obvious that
this
doesn't have much of an impact
representative herbert
has a question a commission a question
to the chair
okay is it uh representative is it
harrington yes um
what's stopping the representative from
going to what was the opla
uh and requesting uh we don't license we
don't require people's
we don't
we don't discuss people's motives or
objectives or what they're doing when if
you see him you sure the subcommittee
will take it up but
actually i'll get to where i think the
question really should be
and that is uh when you have a study
committee you don't want it to be too
wide range you have a very limited time
which i thought represented butler was
going to go it's a limited time to get
this bill out of committee get it
make a
suggestion for the next biennium
so my preference would be is that you
you call through your list there and
actually identify
specific licenses
that you think that that we could help
normally this is done by eda and dna and
carol has done a lot of this work
already but it's here so we'll look at
it
but
it would be very helpful for me if i
wanted to really
pass this bill is to actually pick out a
license
that that it's worth
considering
absolutely
thank you mr chair i i i agree and and
uh
luckily right right now there's there's
many bills that are addressing that
going through uh edna uh whether it's
athletes agents
uh
actually that went through judiciary but
there there's a host of of bills out
there that peop that representatives
have i identified as as being some of
the most egregious
great so
i i'd be happy to if you could help i'll
represent here because i'm going to say
the same thing to him i mean pick
something out but in terms of just
saying you know go over the transom and
find something you need i guess you
would start with a list of licensures
and say and then
whatever but yeah
you get what i'm looking for absolutely
mr chairman i i i appreciate the
sentiment again our intent our our
support is for the intent behind this
building that's just looking at changes
all right representative has another
question yeah um thank you mr chair get
close to that mike thank you for taking
my question
um as i read the bill it says there is
established no
establish a committee to study the
replacement of certain professional
licenses with mandatory minimum
number one
um someone from the insurance division
came in and spoke about limited
liability insurance um
it would not be workable
and number two um it really a study
committee is it should be studying the
licensures
and not come up with
in the bill
a replacement which would be mandatory
minimum liability insurance if you
want this bill to move forward i think
we need an amendment so that it just
doesn't focus on minimum liability
insurance requirements replacing
licensures
uh thank you for the question
representative i i would agree i i i
think
you know taking a one-size-fits-all
solution to licensure isn't the best
route it again it doesn't
uh limited liability insurance would not
be an effective replacement for every
single license field i i think uh that
that sort of restrains what the the
committee can look at to of some of
these other alternatives uh so i would
tend to agree with you thank you
yeah yeah actually that's the one last
question i have
that chart you showed about all the
different things
where's liability insurance on that
chart
how high up the list is it
so we have uh
it goes through things like market
competition uh consumer uh created
ratings and review aka yelp uber
private certifications which seems like
what the sponsor was going for
uh when it comes to to scuba diving
their private certification
voluntary bonding and insurance is an
option but again it's not
there are many options inspections
regular regulation so where was that on
the level is that down at the near the
bottom or is that it just these are just
in the middle uh but the ranking is not
based on uh what is the best it's it's
what are the options uh based on well i
thought that the the bottom was the was
the best bottom was minimum minimal
minimal regulation so it goes from and
i'd be happy to send this yeah that
would be great
it goes from licensure it's just the the
ranking of burden
uh so the ranking of what someone has to
go through it starts at the bottom with
licensure as the most burden and market
competition yeah just email that to the
committee members that'd be fun
absolutely thank you
thank you for having no more questions
we'll close the public
before we close the public hearing
um the
overnight blue sheet i have one
supporter
uh daniel richardson and
uh
nobody nobody signed in on the blue
sheet all right with that i will close
okay
oh
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
house bill 1048 and hear from the prime
sponsor representative patoosa good
afternoon representative patusek good
afternoon chairman hunt and my esteemed
colleagues on commerce and consumer
affairs
i am here to present house bill 1048
relative to minimum non-forfeiture
amounts under the standard
non-forfeiture law for individual
deferred annuities try saying that fast
the analysis this bill will modify the
interest rate used in determining
minimum non-forfeiture amounts
okay i am introducing
i am introducing house bill 1048 at the
request of the insurance department to
incorporate the recent interest rate for
annuities that was adopted
by the national association of insurance
commissioners
and aic
to their nan
their standard non-forfeiture model law
the insurance industry is very much in
favor of this proposal
heather silverstein is here from the
insurance department to answer and
answer any questions you may have
thank you for your this consideration on
thank you very much okay
we have any questions from the committee
members saying none
thank you very much
okay heather
silverson
good afternoon
you just have to make sure it's on and
pull it close
is that better
closer
good afternoon i'm heather silverstein
i'm general counsel from the insurance
department
and um this bill is again
one where we're trying to sync up our
practice at the department with what the
national association of insurance
commissioners has recommended through
their model law uh is 805 in particular
for the model law that we're talking
about here is for individual deferred
annuities so this is just the situation
when someone has
been making payments on an annuity and
then they stop making payments it's kind
of an accumulation phase then what what
money are they going to get back so it's
the value of their annuity at the time
and then there's other factors that come
in in this law and one of the things
that
happened at the neic was industry was
saying hey you're making it really hard
for us to even market these products
because the interest rates have been so
low you know you take it like u.s
treasury bonds and whatnot but the
interest rates have been really really
low so to
have to use this one percent interest
rate that's not really
working when we have to um
provide this return this non-forfeiture
amount and so that's how it came at the
national level where they reduce the
rate at the national level and again
it's just a floor because if the
interest rate went up there's going to
be some competition there so they could
always charge a higher interest rate
like for what the consumer would get
back if they wanted to
and so um we
like to be um consistent with what other
states do in in this particular area and
so
uh industry is in support of this and so
we're just syncing up our law with what
um other states have done and what the
okay any questions from committee
representative abel
yes thank you for your testimony
my question is
could you
in everyday language explain
what what this uh non-forfeiture
uh interest uh
uh
is all about for those of us who don't
deal with us
ever well so for the best is basically
you know like i said when there is a a
surrender you know like i i've been
paying on an annuity and then i've just
decided i don't you know i don't want to
do this anymore for the consumer they
want to
maybe you should tell them what an
annuity is annuity is uh yes
is is in the life insurance type world
and it's an investment and it's meant
for longer term okay
but what happens is there's times when
somebody just decides i don't want to do
this anymore whether they can't afford
the payments or they don't want to be
they don't want to invest in this
anymore it's an investment product it's
an insurance product that we regulate
um that's not like a securities we don't
regulate that okay
so um i guess that would be the simplest
way so then when the consumer wants to
get out this law is focusing on what are
the minimum amounts that the company
would have to return to the consumer and
it's their value at the time that they
want to get out and then now
the one percent interest rate which was
one of the factors that's the part that
wasn't working because the interest
rates have been so low and i gave the
example of the treasury bonds so that's
why we we made that adjustment so
okay rich
yeah just one quick follow-up so this is
the payment from
the
company to the individual
that it could be paid at a low with a
lower interest rate yes that's correct
okay
thank you very much thank you
acli
is this one of berkey's clients acli
yeah
good afternoon uh mr chairman and
members of the house commerce committee
my name is simon thompson i'm with the
she infini capital group
and
here today on behalf of one of our
clients acli which is the american
council of life insurers the acl acli
members account for 98 percent of
annuity contracts issued in new
hampshire and i'm not going to read this
full testimony that's why i've handed it
out for all of you um but as the
silverstein and representative patousek
said the industry
is in strong support of this bill house
bill 1048 and
i just wanted to
say that this bill will help ensure the
continued availability of important
retirement products for the new
hampshire consumers
that our members represent so with that
i will let you read this
testimony at your leisure and i will end
my testimony
thank you
30 seconds okay
yeah representative matthew later
just a quick question what's the
non-forfeiture rate for life insurance
i am not sure i don't want to answer
that without knowing that for sure
representative
i'm asking this is the lieutenant
colombo
question
explain to me why
allowing
the company to pay
less
i think it's more a matter of the
national standard where the interest
rates have become so low that there is
now needs to be a floor
uh where the companies would reimburse
the uh the consumer at that percentage
um and that's just because of the rates
so this is better for the consumer
because right now they're cutting off at
one so now we're allowing it to go lower
yes representative johnson
thank you for taking my question just so
i understand this because i'm kind of
new to the insurance pieces of this
so if i have an annuity say for a
hundred thousand dollars
just an example
and i
cut off say
three quarters of the way you know after
i don't know 10 years or whatever
i'm only going to get 15 percent
or point 15
of that back
of 1 is that no it's the value that you
have in the annuity plus the interest
over and above that if i'm not mistaken
okay all right so i i just not just
point one five percent of the 100 000.
okay so no i that's why i just wanted
some clarification because i was i was
getting a little confused so that's why
i asked thank you
yeah but let's keep remember the one
percent
was the floor the under one percent they
pay anything so what this is doing is
lowering that threshold so the consumer
okay
question of the chair before
would you just expand upon if it's less
than one percent they don't have to pay
anything yeah that right what what's one
percent
whatever the value of the whatever the
principal value the annuity at the time
of
when you stop paying it when the
you stop paying it so it now has the
cash value to cash out as cash value so
the question was and maybe maybe we'll
have somebody else
miss overseeing explain this better
minimum amount of interest but i'm
saying that you're saying was that the
one percent was assuming it was back in
the days when everybody was going to be
five six was you know the sky was the
limit what interest rates used to be so
in this case what they're saying is it
so for some reason in it was ni naic
model legislation that they had a
threshold of one if it was under one
then there was nothing
the insurance company didn't have to
give you anything so if there's a
non-forfeiture value
of a thousand dollars
they would have to pay you one percent
interest on that
plus the thousand dollars which is the
north forfeiture value or is the non for
forfeiture value one percent
of something so simon what why do we
have yeah
thank you i apologize because because
i'm wondering in an era where interest
rates are fluctuating i understand
i understand generally speaking what the
motivation is because we're living in a
low interest rate environment but we're
also we're facing the prospect of
interest rates rising again and my
concern is if we set this at .15
what would be the deleterious
consequences
for the policy because it's this is just
all this well then who determines what
the interest rate is
uh because it says three percent and one
percent so now we're talking about point
one five to three the range point one
five to three rather than one two three
representative i'm gonna have miss
silverstein oh okay thank you yes the
statue i believe yes
thank you nancy right thank you we don't
need a hired hand too thank you
you're just here to support it you had a
reason why he wrote 30 seconds because
so
again that's heather silverstein from
the insurance department so this i have
the statue printed out
so
the 409 a4
is what we're modifying and we're only
modifying a piece of that
and what this relates to is saying these
are the minimum non-forfeiture amounts
and talking about the paid up annuities
and so
my understanding from what this is is
that your the value of what the annuity
is at the time plus this interest rate
so before it was a one percent
payback now we've lowered the floor and
part of the reason that we set an
example like a dollar amount that a
typical annuity might have been and so
people can do the math thousand plus one
percent of that okay so you're getting
your hundred thousand if that's the
value plus one percent plus the one
percent now the floor is going to be
lower and part of that is because of the
availability of these products
the the industry is saying to us we
can't keep on offering new contracts
with this interest rate
and so if we have to pay the money back
okay if somebody surrenders so we're
they're effectively saying we're in a
non-competitive environment due to the
regulation that we can't go below one
percent exactly and so we're trying to
lower it we then then we will be able to
continue to offer these products and if
the interest rates can go up this is not
a problem because this is just a floor
and then we'll be competing against
other issuers
so that it could be one or one and a
half ago okay got it thank you exactly
and i'm sorry if i caused confusion
before about that because that's what
that's what they were saying is that you
know this is a floor and we compete with
each other so if those rates goes up
we're going to be competing for the
consumers and so but if it goes down we
can't compete anymore we're out of it
we're out of the market right
exactly great okay now representative
mcelroy um i i i think there's a little
bit of uh
misleading information here if what a
current contract would say correct me if
i'm wrong
is that the minimum that a client would
ever get back would be one percent
if somehow so they couldn't pay less
than one percent even if they were
earning less than one percent now we're
putting that threshold down to 15 basis
points
what that also does is means that the
insurance company has to keep less
reserves which in fact would allow them
to credit a little bit of a higher
interest rate on a fixed annuity so i
the
chairman when you said that if they
earned less than one percent they
wouldn't
get it that's that's incorrect they
would they would get one percent
threshold now at 15 basis points i
suspect that in a year or two if
interest rates go up they'll come back
with that and and juice it up a little
bit i think dropping it to 15 basis
points is a little a little excessive
but uh what do i know thank you
okay well that's a good point and i will
say this was uh the change at the neic
was in 2020 so it's been out there for a
little while and uh we haven't made the
change yet but we now saying okay we
need because
new hampshire is a small market
and we would like to encourage like more
insurance products here and consumers to
have choice so we'd rather have
that competitive environment in new
hampshire so that for anybody that wants
these products they can have them
offered to them
but does the question why do we have
anything why don't we just say whatever
the product the company sells
but you know if we have to keep
revisiting every time interest rates
yoyo why why why are we why are we in
the business i assume this is nic model
but it just says it kind of begs the
question why are we doing this when
if it's a if it's a free market out
there
and companies will be competing so why
not just let them have have whatever
they want to have
and i'll have to check but i don't know
that this model has changed uh
like was changing all was long until
2020 i'd have to look into that but it
might have just been the market was the
rate was depressed for so low the
industry was depressed for so long that
it motivated the neic to change to
change it question mr sure yes
representative so so uh to follow did
you in fact uh
see obser empirical evidence to the
effect that insurers were no longer
issuing new
annuities in new hampshire because of
the low interest rates over the course
of the last year or two no did you see a
decrease because we're talking about
the availability of product and this
being effectively a barrier to the
providers because they don't want to
with the current floor of one percent so
what happened with to sales over the
course of the last two years
so for us
we don't
have no idea we don't we don't uh
collect data on sales we just know what
we hear from industry in the ndic as to
why this was problematic and at the neic
just for everybody's benefit
that discussion includes both industry
and consumer advocacy groups and
regulators so it's a
full panel type of discussion when they
go about changing a model law
it does not take a few weeks it takes
months
so recommend mac leader you have a would
you believe i think i can answer his
question the the fact is that
a
fixed annuity which is simply a fixed
interest rate we promise you this for
sales of fixed annuities have gone down
dramatically what they've done is
they've replaced it with a product
called an indexed annuity which simply
says your interest is going to be based
on something such as the s p minus five
points or something like that so it's a
different product has taken place thank
you
it just does beg the question why are we
but we're not talking about the interest
rate being paid on the annuity we're
talking about the interest on the norn
forfeiture value the forfeiture and
what's left yes yes
and um marty mobley our legal
coordinator just pointed out to me the
actual
the last time this particular law was
changed here for us was 2004 you know
for this particular so it's it's been a
while oh of course i remember that you
know
this is 409 rsa 409 a colon 4. but
that's that that's the law that we're
trying to change here
representative johnson
um i understand why you're doing it
would it make more sense to
word it so that it's
instead of having to keep revisiting us
every what five or ten years to change
the
fix it so it's just
x
on the and
yeah like a formula
rather than just keep changing the rate
every five to ten years based on so this
is this is a question over her pay grade
okay and this goes back to nic models
okay and one of the one of my my floor
speeches when we talk about insurance is
the one thing you want to do is not be
different than other states
that the more uniformity
conformity to uniformity
gets you
more companies to do business in your
state because we're talking about
attracting somebody who's you know some
who knows know where they are but we
want them to do business in new
hampshire so if they know
that we got remember we get that aaa
rating because we're right on the money
with our nic model legislation then uh
they're more apt to do business in the
state and and i can respond to this in
another practical matter okay so the
idea of not being different so we
approve rates and forms at the
department and if a company has to ch
these are required provisions that have
to be in the contract if a company has
to change their
terminology for new hampshire
they're not going to bother there's not
there's not enough business to do that
exactly exactly thank you i appreciate
that help me understand it more thank
you well this was a good lesson this is
a good thing to get our arms around
right good nic day
thank you thank you
okay and i have no more cards left
and
i have uh
this is still 10 for
who is this guy daniel richardson
he supports this bill
and then the
the blue shield
is uh marty obviously supports the bill
and then uh nathan furness
from petty flairty
which represents aig and is also in
support of the bill
okay with all that i will close the
okay uh just remind everybody blurbs we
need to get anything get
any blur any motion so
uh yours sooner the better
out late bill was
open up the public hearing on house bill
1582 and hear from the prime sponsor
representative tourism
hi good aft afternoon and thank you mr
chair and members of the uh
commerce committee
the commerce consumer affairs committee
i should say
for the record my name is peter teroshan
i represent rockingham county district
14 the towns of atkinson and plaistow
i come here today to ask you to consider
an ought to pass motion for house bill
1582 fn
this is an act repealing the granite
state family leave plan
i believe that this act goes against the
granite state way
it will be very cost costly and this
is not the time to add this kind of
entitlement
it is already difficult for employer
employers in the state to find employees
in this current environment we find
ourselves in
there are already insurance plans
available that won't cost the state
taxpayers
many impr many private employers
add this benefit if their employers
employees
request it so in other words if there's
a need for it
private business
will consider it
however this plan
only adds the benefit to state
i'm going to go over some of the the uh
the concerns i have some of the points
this program costs taxpayers
real money it's not you know it comes
out of the taxpayers
fmli
is bad policy that's getting uh
you know has been put into the rsas and
i don't think it should be done that way
i don't believe that state government
should be in the business of adding this
entitlement
and i believe it will cost more than
what they've projected but looking at
the initial numbers
family medical leave act has been
promoted as a voluntary program
but in fact it would co would again use
taxpayer money without even requiring it
being negotiated on behalf of the
employees that will receive it
this will
create a chain reaction where other
employee groups
will ask to be put on the program
in in increasing and bloating the cost
uh to run the program
this creates a new state
department as you as you've probably
seen if you looked at the bill
that will oversee
this will very likely lead to an income
in
one other point very important point
this bill never had a hearing the bill
was this this
um
bill was put into the budget
and so it never had a hearing i think
uh entitlement program of this size and
significance should have a hearing
so that
legislators members of the public
can weigh in
on the program that never happened
so for all those reasons and more i ask
you to consider
to um
to to pass this bill so we can repeal
the
the family medical leave
plan and with that i would take any
questions that committee members may
have
represented bartlett has a question
thanks very much mr chair
um you seem to know how much this is
going to cost how much is it going to
cost
because my understanding is the rfp
isn't due until march
that's true we don't know that and if
you look at in that's if you look at the
fiscal note that's what they talk about
and the very fact we don't know what's
going to cost is another point that i
didn't uh bring up but i will now
it's concerning to me that we we pass or
put in the legislation something that we
don't even know what's going to what the
final bill is going to be
so the reason i i believe it's going to
cost more than what was projected i
could get you a number if you like i
don't have one with me today oh so
you're an insurance agent no
no
but
there have been projections done on this
and
and i indicated my remarks i believe
it's going to cost more than what was
what people were anticipating because of
the fact that
more employees are probably going to
demand this
at the state level hence
adding cost to it also i'd like to point
out in the fiscal note if we repeal this
act
the money that that's being put into
this program to implement it and to fund
it
uh the insurance premiums uh would go
back um according to what it says in the
fiscal note it would it end up in the
education fund so that money could be
used in better ways than than doing this
for the question
so
um i have just to be clear you don't
know how much it's going to cost it is a
voluntary program um so people that
don't
want to be to participate in it don't
have to participate in it
but you still want to repeal it because
because you think this money
somehow would go into the education
program which education program i'd be
glad to read you the um
the fiscal note
i don't think that's necessary so if i
re if i'm reading this thing correctly
it it appears the money the money is
initially from the
insurance premium tax
and that if the
if you're not funding if i'm reading
this correctly if they're not funding it
then the money would go back to
the general fund which is where the
premium tax is but but it also mentions
the uh
the
education fund so i'm not sure exactly
what's the division there in terms of
how how that
money but theoretically
the the monies is the premium it's the
premium taxes where the money that seems
representative burroughs
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question my question is you
said that it sounded definitively that
this program will lead to an income tax
and um i wonder
how how you came to that given that we
don't know what the cost is or where
your data would come from
okay thank you for the question
representative so what i said is likely
lead to an income tax and the reason i
said that is because when i look at the
cost that other states uh have incurred
doing this it's a it's a program that
usually grows
um quickly
and i
know and have family members that work
for for private companies that have a
similar program
and
the reason why it generally
grows in cost is because in many cases
when somebody goes out on a family
medical leave type
paid leave
the oftentimes they stay longer than
they they anticipate and many
employers have indicated
that
it's sometimes hard to get people back
to work in the time frame they expected
so if that's the case and again i'm only
going on what um you know i've seen and
heard
with other states that have implemented
this and with private businesses that
have done it that it could very likely
uh if it grows in size lead to an income
tax that's that's a concern
further question may inquire
my follow-up is have you have you have
do you have documentation of
increases in income tax
well only that the
so the other states that i'm aware of
that have implemented already have an
income tax so it didn't add an income
tax
however um the cost of the program has
grown and if it's not funded other ways
that could lead i'm speculating could
lead to an income tax
you're welcome representative mcaleer
correct me if i'm wrong but i thought
the only funding that the state would uh
be involved in is the administration of
the plan and even that could be passed
off to a
to some private insurance company so i i
guess i don't understand
why you're saying the cost of this is
going to arise because the premiums are
paid by the
that's true however you know and i'm not
in the insurance company i know some of
you in here are
if the if the program
uh grows
bigger than what
the initial projection was in other
words right now the way i understand
it's going to affect 11 000
give or take
employees
if it's
given to
other
state employees that number could could
go up substantially
and um
depending on
you know if the program's implemented
the number of people that use it and go
out on medical leave that will add
the potential premium costs to go up
because of um
you know
based on employers i've talked to their
costs have risen over the years because
again people are using the program
that's great but oftentimes they stay
out perhaps a little longer than it is
anticipated and that you know insurance
companies are in the business of losing
money they have to fund it somehow
for the question you may inquire uh
if if a private employer has this and if
the private employer is paying for it i
can see that that the cost might go up
and affect the employer but in the case
we're talking about the costs could go
through the roof and if long as this
program is voluntary the uh state
employee can either opt in or opt out so
it doesn't affect the state at all and
you run something like this digitally
whether there's 11 000
participants or 20 000 participants it's
not double the cost it's it's a minimal
cost to to add additional people because
they're paying the premium all the state
is doing is administrating the plan
and do you have any estimates of what
the planned administration cost would be
i don't perhaps somebody else testifying
after me may have those numbers i only
know that the um
again looking at other places where this
is done oftentimes the number
of people
requesting or demanding that the uh
the program goes up
and again
so let me let me know um
this committee actually did hear the
family leave statute the bill
uh obviously this one is different than
than what we heard the one we heard was
going to be mandatory
to employers and that's why it was uh
accused of being an income tax because
the employers had to do it
in my understanding there and again i'm
reading all this for the first time and
you know we'll have a subcommittee to
work through this but
my understanding the initial money
was to get the program off the ground
and that it would the money would be
returned
once the the fund the program got going
now
under that assumption was that uh that
in this case that the the state is
adding some employees so they're giving
some critical mass but at the end of the
day the program theoretically
would be uh was paid you know whether
the employer had the choice so whether
they wanted to take the full amount of
money out of the paycheck or cover it
themselves
but in terms of what the state of new
hampshire would do is yes it would be
the full cost or whatever the employee
is because we would have to renegotiate
our contract with the state employees so
at this point there is some cost related
to the state to
have the state employees participate but
at the end of the day the initial monies
was really just to get the program off
the ground and there would be a separate
uh insurance and that's what the world's
going out to bid right now is the uh who
is going to be the administrator of the
program and obviously they're going to
want to cut but they're the ones who are
supposed to make sure manage the money
manage that the money the amount of
money that actually pays out is relative
to how much is getting paid in and
plus getting paid their fee
with the expectation at some point in
time the state would be refunded for
what our initial costs to get the
program off the ground
but
but it's uh it's also my um
understanding that the
the there's a new state
agency
or you know employees have been added to
this is absolutely through the
department of labor uh and and the way
we were way way they showed it to us was
was the unemployment excuse me and the
way we the way they showed it to us is
that
their the scheme and i'll use the word
scheme
was that just like an employer
pays the
unemployment
for their employees there would be there
would be another field in that form the
unemployment form and that would be uh
allocation for payroll for this for this
fund so
it would be administrated through the
state through uh employment security and
that's obviously there's going to be a
cost
to the employment security to to make
that operate but right now employment
security is funded through
that what we charge uh you know
unemployment tax now so and say in terms
of where where's the impact of the
general fund the impact of the general
fund is we're taking money out of the
general fund now or education general
fund that normally would go there from
the premium tax
the insurance premium tax so that's
where the source where the money
followed the trail of the money but that
um if i'm reading this correctly again i
don't know but but it but yes it would
create a new department a person in the
department and that fees
the whole argument around was
making sure that any insurance company
would operate which is the payout can't
be
greater than how much money they're able
to collect
through the fees and collecting the fees
for whatever is assessment paid
representative johnson do you have a
question
thank you so
as you just explained to chairman hunt
and hopefully if i get this right so
if the funds started going growing
higher than what we already took out of
the taxpayers we would then have another
line that employee employers would now
have to pay
to offer the state employee
this fund because we would have to you
would have it as a like you said the
unemployment tax there would be another
line of tax at employers or
private employees would have to pay on
through unemployment
so basically you're saying another tax
for
residents of new hampshire
in in a roundabout way yes okay so it is
a tax
it would absolutely be a tax
uh the way it was supposed to be
considered now obviously it was
different the bill we had was all
employers had to participate in it
but which then that's why we labeled it
at income tax
but because it's on income payroll on
payroll income
the issue would be that if this is
voluntary that the employer chooses to
do it
that yes that employer will that all
employers who are participating in the
program
would have to pay more if the if there
were too much claims to it
the state employees portion which i
obviously um i i don't know anything
about that because that was not in the
bill that we had
three or four years ago
my understanding was that the state
employees actually
have a family leave type program now
and so that the monies were supposed to
be really what we're spending now in
what they're already offering but i do
not know that for a fact okay so i don't
know obviously we need to learn more
whether that's true or not but at the
end of the day i i would say the the
fundamental question is is if if the
bill says today
that any employer may join it if the
the fear is that suddenly we all were
not here anymore and there was somebody
else in charge of our legislature and
our governor and they decided to make it
a shall
like the original plan was
then they would that we have facilitated
that from happening theoretically they
could do that anyways even if we hadn't
created this model ahead of time
mr chair with your indulgence could i
just add a point based on what
the conversation is
and that is there are many people that
have questions and
and there's some uncertainty to
the costs in in this program so
that lends
to the idea that
if we repeal this and somebody wanted to
bring it back then we could have a
hearing on the bill
and and have these details worked out
before you pass the bill which is you
know with this one it's kind of put in
the car before the horse we have all
these uncertainties and my experience
has been um
particularly with with government
agencies that if
you don't know the number chances are
the numbers you know over time is going
to grow and and that's my concern
we didn't get a public hearing on this
it was put into the budget and these
many people would like i think to know
more on the details so this is one way
we could get there we could repeal it
and then you know if somebody wants to
bring a bill forward and have a hearing
on it and then hopefully those details
would come out uh
much more precisely thank you i will
hope with the next month we'll learn all
we need to know that's true
yes representative bootleg thank you mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um
so this bill was passed and signed by
the governor
so he
supports granite state paid family leave
plan obviously
so
and i believe this is do you believe
that this is good for families and
in in the state of new hampshire and
just um really just answer that you know
if the governor supports this
and
you're the party of the governor
currently um
why would you go against the governors
yeah i don't know where you're going
with this now no i'm just saying the
governor the governor we're forgetting
about the governor
your question was don't you think this
is a good thing for families
that was the first but i also wanted to
remind him that the governor did sign
this bill
okay that but that's not really
appropriate question we don't talk about
people's motives
all right
so um just um explain to me
do you think your constituents um um
like this bill the family leave plan
in all honesty i haven't had any
constituents tell me they do like the
program um
and you know
either
is there some merit to having a plan
where you go to family leave for various
items yes
but again i have a
an acquaintance that works for insurance
company in massachusetts that company
enacted and provided
a family medical leave program that they
fund i i'm assuming through insurance i
don't really know but one of in this
particular individual is in management
down there one of the problems they have
is when people go out on a legitimate
reason oftentimes the it's very
difficult
to get them to come back to work while
the while the benefits being paid in the
crisis has
um subsided then it's it's oftentimes
difficult to get people back another way
i would answer the question is
this there's many companies and i think
government agencies that when you have a
problem at home they are sympathetic to
that and there's ways to do it without
you know in a short period of time i'm
not talking months and months
to help that employee out without having
representative johnson so isn't it true
that you can already buy a
plan similar to this privately any
individual you can go out to an
aflac is a is a perfect example because
your
physical
ailments this this is
giving you money to stay home take care
of somebody
i do believe they have a plan like that
too
what so it's mine so i think what you're
referring to representative and thanks
for the question is that there are
programs um
various catastrophic uh programs for
people but
it's also uh from what i've read there
are programs that businesses use to you
know they fund this partially through
insurance so it's my understanding there
is is some availability of coverages
there
afflack will cover you for you as an
individual if you have to stay home and
have to leave work but aflac does not
have a program for family
or
you know
you know affiliates
so you're the only ty it's helping you
out that flick is for you but not for
if you're at home taking care of a sick
kid
so
it is somewhat unique
but
all right thank you very much
you're welcome
okay the chair will call on
so you just you already got boned up on
this bill so you know more about this
bill than we do
mr chairman i know more about this than
i care to know
thank you mr chairman representative len
turk i represent stratford county for
which is the town of barrington i
currently serve on the
several committees
labor committee finance two
redistricting and i'm also a senior
advisor in the house majority office
most importantly is
i've had
a lot of experience with these these
bills uh back when i was in the house my
last term
uh that was when senator feltus tried to
put through a
bill that would have mandated a as you
said before a tax of a half percent
uh on the entire every everybody in the
state of new hampshire i was the point
man on our committee on that i worked
with the department
on those uh those issues and the numbers
so very familiar there on this
particular issue i'm also very familiar
because i served on finance 2 which was
i'll get into a little bit more of the
history of why we are where we are and
finance 2
was involved
with this and then i ended up on the
committee of conference for hb2
where this
was the fine one of the two final issues
so first thing i want to talk about is
when this was discussed by the promoters
uh governor sununu he sent it over in
hb2
it was sold as a voluntary and a private
insurance plan and that is
not true it's partially true but not
true
for the 10 11 000 state employees
employees would be
given this program
cost free
without the need to negotiate the
benefit
now and later on we can talk about
numbers and what the potential cost is
on that but ten thousand eleven thousand
state employees would get this at the
for free at the uh on the backs of the
taxpayers
so what's going to happen
after that the the idea was to make this
a private insurance plan that other
employees in the state would use well
let's go through this logically and see
what's going to happen number one
plans like this are extremely expensive
we don't know we passed this through the
house without ever knowing what the bill
was going to be
to fund the eleven thousand state
employees a year it's going to be a huge
figure and we'll talk about that to the
end
but private employers
are not going to use this program
they're simply not going to use it
because it's going to be too too
expensive
and again we'll talk about the costs
a little bit later
so what's going to end up happening
is it's going to end up being a
entitlement program for the state
workers
11 000 of them
after that
when no private individuals get involved
with the system
then
the other
public sectors are going to be coming to
the state or to their local school
boards towns say hey state employees are
getting this paid for on their tax
dollars why aren't we getting it so it's
going to turn into a
program
for for the benefit of the public public
sector
private employee employers are not going
and of course once it
becomes law and it's finalized of course
legislate this legislative will to
eliminate it at that point it's going to
be too late
so let's talk about where we are in the
program right now right now um
the
executive committee just approved 1.9
to give to a company to go out and look
for bids
and implement the system 1.9 million
that's just to get the program up and
started
the plan itself won't go into effect if
it goes into effect until the very end
so now let's i'll hit a few general
points and then we'll get into a little
more specific
program like this
strictly incentivizes people
really to take advantage of the program
and if you remember back
or you may not remember back but when
the issue came up uh senator feltus's
bill
the only way to make an fmli
plan like this
work
if you want to call it work making it
is to force everybody into it with a tax
you cannot do an opt-in system and when
we had the senate senator feltes plan
last time
once it was determined that there was no
way we were going to make a
you know
a mandatory program for every employee
in the state
they attempted to bring it back to an
opt-in opt-out that just makes a plan
even more unsustainable than it uh it
would be under uh forcing so it just
and
interesting point i mean have we learned
nothing during the last couple of years
when you pay people to stay home and
work it doesn't incentivize to work why
would a private employer now get into a
program
that's going to incentivize his
individuals
the opportunity give the opportunity to
not work and get paid when they can't
find employees now that's another reason
why private employers are just not going
to go along with this
um a lot of companies offer some form of
a paid leave now or a combination of
personal day sick days vacation days
they roll them all into one basket and
you know they give the individuals that
time now
and the companies that do that and we've
had them testify before labor they do it
because it they they believe it helps
them sometimes to retain and hire the
employees
by giving them that that kind of a
basket of days days off
another way that individuals could
take advantage of a
paid time off because
federal law
requires an employer to allow an
individual to have time off through
family leave it's unpaid in most places
but there's a requirement so there's
there's nothing that prevents an
individual and i had i don't have them
with me but i had calculated one time
how little money it would take for an
individual to put aside each month to
actually
pay for a self-insured benefit at some
point should they need
to take time off to care for
under the family medical leave plan
as i said before private insurance plans
and as i also said before the only way
to make it work is to force people uh
into it when we were talking about the
uh senator feltz's plan before
um when they had uh nixed the idea of
going to a mandatory
tax
and they went to an opt-in
give you an example of
why an opt-in system
doesn't work properly timed if an
employee
could opt into a system
pay two hundred fifty dollars in
premiums
and take out a five thousand dollar
event benefit the following year
that's why an opt-in opt-in
opt-in
system just
now let's talk about the states that
have
paid family medical leave because we
hear about those all all the time let's
california new york new jersey rhode
island connecticut massachusetts
washington and oregon
are those really the states that we want
to emulate these are the states not only
that have some of the highest tax rates
in the country but these are the states
that people are
fleeing
net negative migration to get away from
some
such
uh
states
you know when we
there were
matter of fact in the preamble to the
hb2 language they talk about uh
they believe that this is a way to in
you know get people to come to the state
work for us and this and that
people don't come to the state because
you've got a fmli plan they go to the
states where there's low tax and you can
you know you can do well and not be
so let's talk about how we got to where
we are
okay hb2 when governor sent it over to
us last year included
in the house we
worked extremely hard to get it removed
from hb2
because we knew if we couldn't get it
out of hb2
it would not a budget would have not
come out of the house this year
and after a bunch of work
several of us were
able to get it removed
and we finally passed a budget and went
over to the senate
i'll just say there was pressure on them
to put
and at the very end of the process
at the end of the committee conference
i'm not going to get into the gory
details but it did end up
now
a lot of people don't know a lot about
this plan
i bet you most of you don't know a lot
about this plan and the reason you don't
know about it because
nobody promoted it
why didn't
anybody promote it i heard this
representative here talk about before
about
governor sununu and his influence
but the reason it wasn't
promoted because it's a horrible program
right after the budget was passed and
signed
i was at several meetings where
the executive governor
the senate
president
and the
speaker of the house
spoke about all the glory of the hb2
issues that we had passed and not once
was fmli
mentioned
it's because it's a bad issue it's a bad
campaigning issue
and it's not a
i was in a labor committee hearing
earlier and nobody testified nobody was
there from anybody's office to back it
up
there's nobody here from any of the
branches that i just mentioned
to back it up that's because it's a bad
policy
fiscal points financial points i heard
several people asking about
how much this would cost
now i'm not going to give you exact
numbers
because it's based on a lot of variables
a lot of these variables i worked with
with the commissioner when senator
felsice's plan was here and it takes a
lot there's a lot of things involved
i will say that during our last
few years back
we had a firefighter testify that he
carried private insurance that was cover
very similar um
lengths of time and under certain
circumstances actually there were a
little less and at that time he was
paying 60 a week
for his plan 240 bucks a month
the numbers that
are shown in here in the hb2
five dollars a week something like that
it's insane there's no way that's going
to work
so what kind of numbers are we looking
at do you think for just to pay for the
11 000 state employees
that's based on what they call an uptake
rate
how many people are going to use it
we don't know that number
you'll hear the the actuaries they'll
say anywhere from four eight as high as
ten percent and when you start talking
those numbers i'll just throw out a
couple ones for you to consider
just to pay for those
uh
eleven thousand state
without considering the fact that once
eight percent of those employees take
the the leave
how are you going to cover that lost
time you're going to cover that lost
time with overtime are you going to have
to carry extra employees
i mean those are all kinds of numbers
you gotta figure in and
this says nothing about them
nothing
when you look at
an eight percent uptake ten percent
uptake you're talking somewhere between
nine and twelve million dollars a year
just for those ten to eleven thousand
employees
so this is not an insignif insignificant
uh plan
um it's
not a total voluntary plan
the taxpayers are picking up the tab for
the eleven thousand
so with that i will be happy to
and i do rise in support
representative uh thank you uh thanks
for taking our questions i i guess i'm
totally confused because i understood
that the only bill that sununu would
pass was a voluntary bill which by the
way i agree with you that that's never
gonna work but i thought that that's
exactly what this is and you're telling
me it's not and yet sununu said the only
thing he would pass
would not be a compulsory mandatory uh
but totally voluntary so i'm wrong is
that correct
you're partially wrong correct um 11 000
state employees will get this as a paid
taxpayer benefit period
then they opened it up for voluntary
to private businesses and actually you
could be voluntary for other public
sectors
but then it becomes uh voluntary for
private businesses what i'm telling you
is when you consider the costs involved
private businesses are not going to do
this
it's just too too expensive
so basically what it ends up being is
simply a
as of now when it goes into effect it'll
be a taxpayer paid benefit for 11 000
state workers period
any other questions from the committee
members
uh representative burroughs
yeah i'd just like to ask you it's and
this is a a what-if scenario okay
we let's say we have a state worker
single mom
has has children one of the children
becomes very sick and the mom needs to
be with that child um why wouldn't they
be motivated to go back to work if
they're a single parent and they need to
feed their family and um what would the
impact be on the state
if we had people who needed to care for
sick and dying family members
what would that do to the management and
running of the state
i don't have an answer for that i'm not
okay
thank you very much thank you
they have one other card uh amanda sears
campaign for family
friendly economy
now you don't write whether you support
her against the bill
okay
okay so you need to push the button
and keep that thing close to you okay
all right thank you
my name is amanda sears i'm the director
of the campaign for family friendly
economy and i thank you for the time i
can answer a lot of the questions you
were asking earlier and clear up a bunch
of the
misconceptions
between what the program you heard
before and this program they're very
different and so i'd be happy to do that
i also did prepare things that i wanted
to say that will take my three minutes i
told you about so if i'm able to answer
your questions later about that or clear
those things up i'd really be happy to
okay
i do want to say um you know i come at
this from a very different perspective
than the couple of speakers before me um
you know paid family and medical leave
is a very important for workers and
businesses and the economy and the
pandemic has only underscored the value
of having a system for ensuring that
people can take the time they need for
medical emergencies without putting
their financial security at risk but the
governor's program that is now the the
policy
would artificially prop up a private
insurance provider and it is not an
effective paid leave program that meets
the needs of granite staters
what the legislature should do is repeal
this program and replace it with one
that covers all working people so that's
why my position was not like an easy
check mark there um and we would be in
support of an amended version of this
bill that would repeal it and replace
the program that's currently in statute
the the previous speakers were right
there were no public hearings um
surrounding passage of this program and
that means that there has been no due
diligence to solve the many many
problems and unknowns that exist with
this program
like access cost implications etc and
those things should be considered to
build a program that would work
this program entirely leaves out a path
for employees of employers with under 50
people
if i could back up and just describe um
if i would have a couple more a little
bit extra time than the three minutes
there's three different pieces of this
program one is the state employees
coverage that would be done through a
contract with the state
to a private insurer to fund the to
cover the benefits for those private
employees the second piece is a tax
incentive to private businesses to
encourage those businesses to pick up a
contract with that same insurer um in
order to build the pool of people who
would be participating and those
contracts would be directly between the
employee that employer and the insurance
company but they would get a half of
their payments that they pay in premium
returned as a credit to the business
profits tax
um and so that could be a significant
cost and you know i didn't have figures
to say what exactly that is the third
piece of this program creates an
individual pool which would be
run by the department of employment
security
um and that would the department of
employment security would be the
collections agent for the premiums from
individuals and then turn those over to
the private insurer who would administer
the program so that's just to say a
little bit about
how it's structured because i don't
think that was necessarily clear earlier
um
the so
for the
employers that would have um so right
now the there's not a path there's not a
path at all for people in companies with
less than 50 employees
to get this program to get this benefit
unless their employer opts in to cover
all of the people
so there's not a path for those people
to participate in the individual pool
and employees of those small companies
already are less likely to have this
benefit
but employers that do decide to opt in
and cover their employees they would get
the competitive edge to say they offer
the benefit but then there's nothing in
here
you know they'd get a publicly
subsidized rate and on or tax credits
but they could also deny employees to
take the benefit there's nothing that
you know um
that keeps them from punishing people
you know firing people for actually
taking the benefit
when they need it so they could be
retaliated against even though these
would be you know publicly subsidized
benefits
uh they also
there's there's a lot of complications
about what if people work for two
employers you know one that's bigger
than 50 one that's smaller they'd be
eligible in certain part of their hours
and not eligible in certain other parts
of their hours the insurance company
would have control of the cost of
premiums the rate setting which could
lead to higher costs for employers with
more women or people with disabilities
they would be able to deny claims and
make the decisions about that to save on
the cost of benefits they would have to
pay out and there's no process outlined
for appeal of denied claims or even
jurisdiction of who's responsible for
who those appeals would be made to
there
also is um
it's silent on
i'm sorry
my pages are messed up sorry about that
um it's silent on essential operating
questions like what if an employee
purchases the independent coverage for
leave but the employer fails to grant
the time off what if the employer
recognizes the time for leave but the
independent insurer denies coverage how
are these disputes resolved there's
nothing to indicate how that's done
so the state would just be acting as a
collections agent for the private
insurer
and i haven't seen a legal opinion on
whether it's okay for the state to
charge low-income people in the
individual pool the same premium as
higher income people but provide them
with significantly different benefits
because the way that the individual pool
rate is set right now is that people
would pay up to five dollars for the
benefit but then what they would get and
it's that's not differentiated between
what they earn you know they would pay
up to five dollars it would probably be
five dollars
the state would pay any cost over that
so that's another um thing that is in
the bill
and then um
whether they make 130 000 or 12 an hour
they would be their benefits are based
upon their wages so they're the benefit
would be paid out very differently for
low income people versus high income
people even though they're paying the
so just the bottom line
the reason that there's been demand for
state policy for paid leave is because
two-thirds of working people don't have
it and there's significant disparity
between who has it and who doesn't and
the people least likely to have paid
leave are working people with the lowest
incomes and the most significant
caregiving responsibilities
public policy should be used to
eliminate that disparity but this
program will not do that it perpetuates
the status quo
it seeks to artificially prop up a
private insurance market that's failed
to function on its own with no actual
commitment to ensure working people will
great so uh my memory in the original
bill
that part-time employee if you worked
less than 30 hours you could never make
a claim and yet you were still being
taxed you still excuse me you were still
being assessed
unless your employer was covering it
himself that uh did they solve that
problem that was never the that was
never a situation um it was based the
both the premium and the payout of
wage of wage replacement were based upon
the number of hours worked what you
might be remembering is that there was a
just like there is for unemployment
insurance a requirement to work a
minimum of seven thousand five hundred
dollars
worth of wages in a certain period of
time there was that minimum that was you
know that people would have to it was 30
hours i was pretty positive it was
something that said you had to work 30
hours no that was never the situation
okay with this bill or with that one
okay all right uh representative amen
has a question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
uh the bill before us is a repeal bill
and it sounded like you have many issues
with the program that's in place so
would you be in favor of repealing this
program
and then coming back later and
instituting a program much more to your
liking
i think that the problems involved with
this program really need to be solved um
and
there are many ways to do that i think
we
you know the way that we see it is that
we should solve these problems by
creating a program that works and the
way that a program would work would be
to cover everybody and have a pool that
would uh be large enough by to be able
to deal with adverse benefits i mean
adverse selection of benefits for the
question follow-up
so are you in favor of this bill or are
you against this bill i'm confused i'll
tell you what i'll tell you what i wrote
on your card uh she is supports the bill
with amendment that's what that's
for the question you may inquire
and so
your testimony was describing an
amendment that you'd like to see
to completely change this building it
would be describing an amendment that i
know would not pass this legislature but
that amendment would repeal this program
and replace it with a program that would
representative johnson so would you be
in favor of us
of supporting this repeal
and then late and then coming up
later on with a better program
because this has so many flaws in it
that i think it would be more convoluted
to try to fix it now the way it sits
i um benefit from not being somebody who
will actually be pushing a green or a
red button and so my position is that i
would support this with an amendment
okay that's half a loaf
either way you go
i think it's important to know what the
problems are because i think because
this never had a public hearing
there's not a process for solving all
these problems and in the absence of
solving the problems we're saying that
we're we're meeting in need and meeting
up
and we're not meeting that need and so
uh i think that's a really important
point
representative burroughs just two
seconds i just checked to see if i had
gotten it have you could you send out um
the information that you were presenting
would be really helpful or something
sure that we can have a reference thank
you
representative bielem thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question
who do you represent
i work for an organization called the
campaign for a family friendly economy
and it's a new hampshire-based advocacy
organization that works to advance
policies that help people to make ends
meet and be there for their families
when they need to be
a non-profit organization and just a
further question you may include a
follow-up
how can you guarantee or your group that
another bill will come forward within
the next
two years i offer no such guarantee okay
so uh how did you feel about the feltus
version of the bill um that was a
different program and we supported it
wholeheartedly
aggressively
there you go okay
any other questions
see none we thank you very much oh we do
yes
this program that's presently in place
yes or that will soon go into motion or
whatever uh is is voluntary does that
mean that only those people who have
volunteered to pay for it will pay for
it
well voluntary in the sense that uh not
because if we don't talk about the state
employment everybody has to partake on
it
is it only those people who volunteered
to pay for it let's just take the state
employees out of the suit yes
the answer is no
because
the the taxpayers have not volunteered
to pay for the state employees
but they can volunteer to pay for
themselves
so the answer is no thank you very much
um
to ask you to answer your question
we are a representative government we
are a republic so the taxpayers
are not ever given
a direct opportunity to vote on what we
do here as a matter of fact we're one of
the few states that don't even let a
citizen referendums
that what we do have
is us so if we were to fund the money in
the budget
and vote for that budget
then yes for all types of purposes it it
would hold true
that only people who elect to be in it
have voted to be in it
until we get
okay i have no more cards
and we have um
uh
seven people in support
six opposed
and we have
uh al balozaro and len turcotte in
support and with that we will close the
i my new vacation days
my new vacation dates are
um
you